bem-vindo de volta ao Computação Quântica na Prática, eu sou sua apresentadora Olivia Lanes. Na última vez, percorremos um exemplo de uma
abordagem de Computação Quântica para um problema de otimização conhecido como Max cut, usando a formulação Cubo. Fomos
bem fundo no assunto, mas aquele era apenas um exemplo de uma abordagem. Hoje vamos discutir aplicações de curto prazo
de forma mais ampla e desenvolver nossa intuição para os diferentes tipos de problemas nos quais esperamos encontrar soluções quânticas úteis
e ver alguns exemplos recentes de trabalhos importantes feitos em nossa comunidade na escala de utilidade
anteriormente discutimos brevemente que nem todos os problemas precisam de poder computacional adicional
especificamente Computação Quântica para serem resolvidos de forma eficiente. Esses são os problemas com os quais você já está mais
familiarizado: aritmética, rolar o feed das redes sociais, talvez jogar Tetris, Doom ou outros videogames. Consideramos
esses problemas fáceis. Por outro lado, existem problemas muito difíceis, como encontrar fatores primos de números inteiros
enormes, e essa é a base da criptografia RSA e o que o algoritmo de Shor foi projetado para resolver. Outro
exemplo é encontrar uma solução em um conjunto de dados não ordenado. Isso pode ser resolvido teoricamente pelo algoritmo quântico conhecido
como algoritmo de Grover. Porém, a maioria dos especialistas concorda que esses tipos de algoritmos vão exigir a
implementação de correção de erros, e ainda não chegamos lá tecnologicamente. Portanto, ao avançarmos nesta
lição e na sua jornada educacional quântica, lembra que estamos procurando esse ponto ideal em algum lugar aqui no meio.
É um problema difícil de resolver, mas é exatamente isso que o torna tão divertido. Uma coisa que ainda não discutimos
muito é a teoria da complexidade computacional. Um dos motivos é que pode ser um pouco intimidadora e sim,
complexa. A teoria da complexidade computacional é a área da ciência da computação que visa classificar problemas computacionais
por quão difíceis eles são. Existem muitas classes de complexidade diferentes na computação clássica, mas as mais
fundamentais são os problemas P. Esses são problemas que podem ser resolvidos em tempo polinomial conforme a escala do
problema aumenta, o que significa que são fáceis de resolver. O próximo tipo de problema mais difícil são os problemas NP, que
significam polinomial não-determinístico. São problemas cujas respostas podem ser verificadas em tempo polinomial, mas não
necessariamente resolvidas. Em seguida temos NP-completo, e agora estamos entrando nos problemas realmente desafiadores, sem
solução polinomial conhecida. É aqui que vivem problemas famosos como o problema do caixeiro-viajante e até o jogo
Sudoku. Agora, quando a Computação Quântica surgiu, pelo menos em teoria, as pessoas dedicaram um esforço considerável tentando
descobrir qual classe de problemas esses novos tipos de computadores seriam capazes de resolver eficientemente. Uma nova classe de
problemas foi criada chamada de problemas quânticos polinomiais de erro limitado, ou BQP. Sua definição estrita é um
pouco longa, mas é a classe de problemas de decisão solváveis por um computador quântico em tempo polinomial com uma pequena
chance de erro. Existe uma chance de erro porque a medição quântica é inerentemente aleatória, mas o erro
pode ser arbitrariamente pequeno. Agora, todas essas classes estão dentro de uma classe maior que chamamos de PSPACE, e é onde
achamos que o BQP se encaixa em relação a todos os outros tipos de problemas, mas é muito difícil provar isso definitivamente
de forma matemática. Você vai notar que os problemas quânticos BQP não se sobrepõem necessariamente aos problemas NP-completos.
Porém, você talvez ainda tenha visto algumas abordagens de Computação Quântica que visam resolver problemas NP-completos. Por que
isso? Um equívoco comum é que não faz sentido explorar soluções
para problemas como o do caixeiro-viajante e outros problemas NP-completos para um computador quântico, ou qualquer problema no qual uma
prova matemática de aceleração quântica ainda não foi encontrada. Porém, não precisa ser necessariamente assim.
Encontrar a prova matemática de que um algoritmo quântico é mais rápido do que seu equivalente clássico é raro. Shor e
Grover são dois dos únicos poucos exemplos onde isso foi feito até agora, mas tudo bem. Na verdade, os cientistas da computação
ainda não conseguiram provar que as classes P e NP são diferentes, mesmo que toda a intuição
nos diga que devem ser. Além disso, comparar dois algoritmos e como eles escalam muitas vezes analisa o pior caso
para cada um. É bem possível que na prática o pior caso não seja o que encontramos na vida real. Então
não vamos desanimar: introduzimos em vez disso a ideia de soluções heurísticas. Se você é um
experimentalista, você já conhece e gosta desse tipo de solução. Uma heurística é qualquer abordagem para resolver um
problema que é pragmática, mas não necessariamente ótima. E isso é ótimo porque as soluções não precisam necessariamente
ser ótimas para serem muito úteis. Por exemplo, pensa em uma aplicação financeira. Ainda não encontramos uma
aceleração exponencial para a maioria dos algoritmos financeiros nos quais o quântico poderia ser usado, mas isso não importa necessariamente. Não precisamos de uma solução ótima
em finanças, pelo menos porque uma solução que seja apenas 1% mais eficiente pode equivaler a bilhões de dólares
em lucro. Então como sabemos quais casos de uso e problemas podem ser adequados para a Computação Quântica agora? Com isso
quero dizer que há razões significativas para acreditar que utilidade quântica ou até vantagem pode ser encontrada agora ou
em um futuro próximo. Talvez seja mais fácil primeiro nomear as coisas que o problema certamente não deve ter. Ele
não pode exigir um número enorme de qubits. Ainda não temos processadores com milhares a milhões de qubits disponíveis. Esse é um dos principais motivos
pelo qual o algoritmo de Shor e similares ainda estão tão distantes. Os circuits também não podem ser incrivelmente profundos. É muito difícil para mim
dizer exatamente qual profundidade de circuit não vai funcionar, porque depende de tantos fatores, mas em geral se o
experimento exige uma profundidade que você ainda não viu alcançada na literatura, pode ser que você terá dificuldades. E
por último, qualquer tipo de algoritmo que sabemos que vai exigir correção de erros ainda não pode ser feito. O que devemos procurar são experimentos que façam
uso da maioria dos qubits disponíveis em qualquer QPU. Também enfatizamos a
importância da mitigação e supressão de erros e, por fim, deve haver uma extensão óbvia para aplicações futuras
que seriam importantes para a sociedade e que poderíamos ver eventualmente levando a
vantagem quântica. Agora vamos falar sobre alguns exemplos de casos de uso que se enquadram em três categorias principais que
identificamos como as mais prováveis de ver resultados favoráveis no curto a médio
prazo. A primeira área é a simulação da natureza. Já falamos sobre isso antes:
há muitas oportunidades para computadores quânticos melhorarem as pesquisas feitas no nível molecular e atômico.
E o motivo é que os métodos clássicos atuais são limitados por descrições matemáticas fundamentalmente ineficientes
de estruturas atômicas. Armazenar e manipular um estado quântico requer uma quantidade exponencial de recursos
em um computador clássico, mas pode ser feito eficientemente em um computador quântico, e é isso que torna a simulação de materiais
e a modelagem química algumas das áreas de aplicação mais promissoras. Mais especificamente, isso poderia levar a
avanços no sequestro de dióxido de carbono, baterias alternativas ou na invenção de novos medicamentos. Alguns
algoritmos especialmente relevantes nessa área são o variational quantum eigensolver VQE, que é usado para
estimar certas propriedades de um material, como estados de equilíbrio ou de energia mínima. Outro exemplo é a
simulação dinâmica temporal TDS, cujo algoritmo é usado para estimar funções de resposta ou propriedades espectrais de
materiais. E quero mencionar também uma novidade: a diagonalização quântica baseada em amostras, que acreditamos que
ouviremos muito mais no futuro próximo. A próxima área de aplicação é a otimização. A otimização é bastante
onipresente na computação, como você pode imaginar, então os casos de uso são bastante numerosos e variados.
Alguns exemplos que ouvimos muito são a otimização de portfólio em finanças, design industrial e também
distribuição e cadeia de suprimentos. O algoritmo mais comum que você provavelmente vai ouvir relacionado à otimização é o que
já cobrimos com alguma profundidade: o quantum approximate optimization algorithm ou
QAOA. Por último, uma área que gerou muito entusiasmo nos últimos anos é o aprendizado de máquina quântico. Bem,
acho que é justo dizer que parece que o QML não vai acontecer tão cedo quanto a simulação, muito provavelmente, mas ainda assim existem
alguns algoritmos impressionantes nos quais as pessoas estão trabalhando constantemente, correspondendo a alguns casos de uso muito importantes.
Alguns desses possíveis casos de uso são o processamento de linguagem natural, análise de tráfego de rede e até
detecção de fraudes em transações financeiras. Algoritmos relevantes nessa área são a quantum support vector
machine, redes neurais quânticas e redes adversariais generativas quânticas. Para esclarecer, esses três
grupos que acabamos de descrever são áreas de aplicação amplas. Vale notar também que na comunidade existe
benefício em grupos que trabalham juntos com foco em um tópico específico. A IBM liderou uma iniciativa não muito tempo atrás
chamada de Grupos de Trabalho para ajudar colaboradores a se encontrarem e criarem sinergia produtiva em quatro áreas específicas:
saúde e ciências da vida, materiais e HPC, física de alta energia e
otimização. Aqui estão nossos grupos atuais e as entidades envolvidas nesses esforços. Se quiser saber mais sobre
o que os grupos de trabalho estão fazendo, incluímos quatro dos seus artigos de posição na descrição abaixo. Como eu disse,
acho que a melhor coisa a fazer neste ponto do curso é passar algum tempo explorando os tipos de problemas nos quais as pessoas estão trabalhando na
vanguarda desta tecnologia e desenvolvendo nossa intuição para saber quais tipos de algoritmos vão funcionar e como
aplicá-los. E antes de começar, quero deixar bem claro que o objetivo principal aqui não é entender cada
detalhe dos experimentos. Esse tipo de análise pode ser muito intimidador até para especialistas se o artigo estiver ligeiramente
fora da sua área de especialização. O objetivo é simplesmente ajudar a desenvolver uma intuição para os tipos de problemas que os
computadores quânticos são bons para resolver e como lidar com eles. E se você estiver interessado nos detalhes mais finos e isso tiver acendido
algumas ideias suas, eu definitivamente te encorajo a ir ler os artigos completos. Os casos de uso específicos e
os artigos que vamos analisar em profundidade são estes: primeiro, vamos explorar um artigo que discute
simulação de dinâmica de hádrons. Isso se enquadra na categoria de física de alta energia. Em seguida, vamos analisar um problema de
otimização, especificamente a otimização quântica contra-adiabática de campo polarizado, e por último vamos analisar um
problema de simulação, mas desta vez com foco em mRNA, uma molécula crucial para o
desenvolvimento de medicamentos e terapias. Se você está familiarizado ou não com esses artigos, tudo bem. Vamos percorrer
todos eles. Os três são artigos importantes que abordam problemas de tamanho substancial e mostram como os
computadores quânticos estão começando a ser usados como mais um método de investigação científica. O primeiro é a simulação de dinâmica de
hádrons, e vamos mergulhar em um artigo do grupo de Martin Savage da Universidade de Washington chamado Quantum
simulations of hadron dynamics in the Schwinger model using 112
qubits. Se você não é físico de alta energia, talvez ainda conheça o termo hádron, como no
Grande Colisor de Hádrons, ou LHC, que é o gigantesco acelerador de partículas com 27 quilômetros de circunferência que tornou possível
observar finalmente o bóson de Higgs. Um hádron é uma partícula subatômica composta formada por outras partículas menores
chamadas quarks. Alguns exemplos seriam nêutrons e prótons. Para um pouco de contexto, o LHC foi construído
para permitir o estudo da física fundamental e o que acontece com as partículas quando colidem em energias super altas
nesse tubo circular. Ao fazer isso, os cientistas esperam aprender mais sobre como o Universo primitivo surgiu
e, como disse antes, também foi usado para encontrar o bóson, que é uma partícula evasiva responsável pela massa das
partículas fundamentais. Em princípio, as interações dessas partículas poderiam ser
simuladas do começo ao fim com um computador quântico suficientemente poderoso. Ainda não chegamos lá, mas progresso
está sendo feito. O modelo de Schwinger é um modelo simples usado para simular algumas dessas dinâmicas e emergiu como um dos
modelos mais populares entre as escolhas. Os detalhes do modelo não são super importantes por enquanto, mas para os
curiosos, é um modelo que descreve o comportamento de elétrons e pósitrons interagindo via fótons em 1+1
dimensões, o que significa que há uma dimensão espacial e o tempo. O modelo tem muitas semelhanças com a
cromodinâmica quântica, que descreve como quarks e hádrons interagem. Isso é extremamente difícil de simular, então o
modelo de Schwinger é frequentemente usado como um modelo de brinquedo para investigar alguns fenômenos que são comuns a
ambos. A forma como vamos prosseguir com este exemplo e com o restante dos exemplos que selecionei aqui é
nos fazendo uma série de perguntas. A primeira é: por que tínhamos razão para acreditar que simular isso
em um computador quântico funcionaria? Neste caso, os elétrons e pósitrons no modelo de Schwinger têm um efeito de blindagem
que faz com que as correlações entre férmions distantes decaiam exponencialmente com a separação, e isso significa que não há
tantas interações de longo alcance de um qubit de um lado do chip para outro do outro lado do chip,
o que sabemos que é muito propenso a erros. Então isso é muito bom para o hardware que temos disponível hoje. Em seguida,
esse tópico é de interesse? Bem, espero já ter te convencido de que sim, a física de alta energia é de grande
interesse. As pessoas estavam dispostas a gastar bilhões de dólares para construir o LHC, e milhares de cientistas e
técnicos ao redor do mundo dedicaram suas vidas a esse campo. É tão importante assim. Mas o
modelo de Schwinger é simplificado e não foi projetado para cobrir três dimensões espaciais. Ainda assim, é um
modelo importante, pois ainda fornece fatias testáveis atualmente e uma simplificação útil de uma
teoria completa. Por último, como esse trabalho foi feito, ou qual abordagem seria usada se quisessem continuar o trabalho em
experimentos do tipo simulação? O VQE é uma das abordagens mais comuns, e o primeiro passo é quase sempre o mesmo:
preparar o estado fundamental. Neste caso é um estado de vácuo, e neste experimento eles usaram uma nova versão do VQE chamada SC-
ADAPT-VQE para preparar tanto o estado fundamental quanto o pacote de onda de hádron sobre o vácuo. O próximo passo é então
deixar os hádrons evoluírem ou se propagarem no tempo. Por último, precisamos identificar os
observáveis que queremos detectar. Agora, se esses passos pareceram de alguma forma familiares para você, menos a parte do pacote de onda de hádron,
é porque esses passos são muito semelhantes ao que cobrimos no exemplo de QAOA no episódio anterior.
Esperemos que você esteja começando a ver alguns padrões emergindo aqui. Os componentes necessários para o VQE são muito similares ao QAOA:
começamos em um estado familiar, aqui o estado de vácuo, e então o deixamos evoluir no tempo com uma série de
hamiltonianos exponencializados divididos em pedaços gerenciáveis onde n é o número de divisões. A única grande diferença aqui
é que criamos o pacote de onda de hádron centralizado dentro do nosso circuit antes de começarmos a deixá-lo evoluir. Então como isso é
feito? Bem, o estado de vácuo é o estado fundamental e já cobrimos de certa forma como fazer esse mapeamento. Agora, preparar o pacote de onda de
hádron é um pouco diferente. Neste vácuo, um hádron pode ser excitado criando um par férmion-antiférmion em
sítios adjacentes. Ao preparar uma superposição de tais hádrons em diferentes locais, um pacote de onda
arbitrário pode ser preparado. Os autores centralizaram seu pacote de onda no meio do circuit para observar a evolução
sem exceder um limite. Mas lembra que o nome do jogo quando se trabalha com QPUs ruidosas é manter a
profundidade do circuit gerenciável. Para fazer isso, o protocolo SC-ADAPT-VQE usa simetria e
hierarquias em escalas de comprimento para determinar circuits quânticos de baixa profundidade para preparação de estados. A ideia é que isso
criará um ansatz com um número menor de parâmetros, equivalendo a uma profundidade menor. Mais detalhes podem
ser encontrados no artigo do que temos tempo para cobrir aqui, então certifique-se de conferir. Agora vamos dar uma olhada nos resultados. Este experimento foi executado em
um dispositivo IBM Quantum Heron e implementou alguns tipos diferentes de mitigação e supressão de erros,
incluindo uma técnica mais recente chamada renormalização de decoerência de operador, bem como desacoplamento dinâmico, extrapolação de
ruído zero e twirling de Pauli. Agora vamos tentar interpretar os dados. O observável que vamos
medir para observar como o pacote de onda se propaga é chamado de condensado quiral, que é um pouco
abstrato, mas é basicamente uma fase superfluida dos hádrons. Podemos ver o pacote de onda centralizado aqui nos
sítios designados para executar este experimento, onde a cor corresponde ao condensado quiral. O
lado esquerdo mostra os resultados sem erros do simulador, enquanto o lado direito mostra os resultados do computador quântico
IBM Torino. Idealmente, esses seriam imagens espelhadas um do outro devido à simetria, então você pode ver que existem
algumas imperfeições. Agora este eixo y vertical corresponde aos pedaços de tempo que
medi anteriormente. Então por que não fazemos alguns cortes horizontais pelo primeiro e último passos de tempo dos dados para ver
o que acontece com o pacote de onda? No instante t=1, aqui em laranja, correspondendo a
este corte, você pode ver que o condensado quiral é estreito e localizado. Também corresponde muito bem à
simulação feita para comparação. No instante t=14, no entanto, está muito mais espalhado e está menos
localizado. Talvez a comparação com o simulador não seja tão perfeita agora, mas você ainda pode ver claramente um acordo muito bom entre a teoria e os dados,
o que é encorajador. Em conclusão, este é um exemplo muito legal do tipo de trabalho de simulação que você pode não pensar inicialmente em
aplicar computadores quânticos. Porém, na verdade, você pode, e funciona. Não é perfeito, mas você não precisa ser um
especialista em física de partículas para ver que o computador quântico prevê com precisão a propagação para fora do pacote de onda,
que é exatamente o que esperaríamos encontrar. Esperemos que trabalhos futuros nessa área continuem e que os físicos de alta energia
continuem encontrando maneiras de incorporar a Computação Quântica em seus fluxos de trabalho. O objetivo é resolver problemas teóricos com mais precisão e
aqueles que não podem ser feitos classicamente, e usar experimentos para aceitar ou rejeitar teorias na esperança de descobrir nova
física, construir detectores melhorados e levar a um melhor entendimento da natureza em seu nível mais fundamental.
Nosso próximo exemplo se concentra em otimização e será um mergulho profundo em um artigo chamado biased field
digitized counter-adiabatic quantum optimization, feito por membros da equipe da KIPU Quantum na
Universidade do País Basco, na Espanha. Vamos começar como fizemos antes,
com uma série de definições. A primeira é counter-adiabatic, que é um tipo de evolução que suprime efeitos não-adiabáticos
experimentados por um sistema, independentemente da rapidez com que esses processos ocorrem. Lembra do teorema adiabático do
último episódio? Normalmente é preciso deixar um sistema evoluir muito lentamente se quisermos que ele permaneça no estado fundamental.
Isso é um grande problema porque quanto mais lentamente precisamos deixar as coisas evoluírem, mais tempo temos para que erros
ocorram. O driving counter-adiabático, frequentemente abreviado como CD, visa combater isso
adicionando termos que neutralizam essas excitações indesejadas. A ideia principal aqui é acelerar o experimento inteiro e
reduzir a profundidade do circuit quântico suprimindo excitações que poderiam levar a transições
espúrias. Agora vamos falar sobre o que é um campo polarizado. Outros algoritmos iterativos como o VQE recebem parâmetros clássicos nesses
estados e usam otimizadores clássicos para percorrer o espaço de parâmetros multidimensional em busca daquele conjunto
que produz um valor de expectativa mínimo para um hamiltoniano fixo. Neste caso, em vez disso, eles variam o hamiltoniano a cada
vez, movendo-se adiabaticamente de um caso conhecido para o caso de interesse. Mas como não há parâmetros clássicos sendo
passados e nem função de onda variacional, como você atualiza seu estado de uma passagem pelo hamiltoniano para a próxima? Bem,
eles adicionam um campo de polarização ao hamiltoniano. Seja qual for o estado de menor energia da execução anterior, eles adicionam um termo no
hamiltoniano para polarizar o estado em favor desse. Então por que esse experimento é de
interesse? Bem, em primeiro lugar, esta é uma nova abordagem que pode ser aplicada de forma mais geral a outros problemas de otimização.
Mas neste caso eles a aplicaram a um problema de vidro de spin de Ising. Como discutimos anteriormente, muitos problemas de
otimização combinatorial podem ser reformulados como a busca pelos estados de baixa energia de hamiltonianos de Ising. O modelo de
Ising é uma série de spins microscópicos distribuídos em um arranjo. O modelo pode ser usado para descrever um vidro de spin no qual
a magnetização é desordenada; basicamente os pequenos momentos magnéticos estão orientados aleatoriamente no arranjo. E
por que achamos que isso funcionaria? Bem, já cobrimos de certa forma como estamos combatendo dois problemas típicos encontrados em
algoritmos variacionais quando cobrimos as definições do artigo. Mas para resumir, o algoritmo que eles estão
propondo acelera a evolução para reduzir a profundidade do circuit enquanto também suprime transições não-adiabáticas.
Além disso, ele não depende de nenhuma rotina de otimização clássica, o que pode ser um problema levando a
platôs planos e ficar preso em mínimos locais. Por último, os autores também se certificam de alinhar as interações no problema
hamiltoniano com a conectividade de hardware da QPU real, o que é sempre muito importante. Por fim, como isso funciona? Então,
como disse, não há otimizadores clássicos sendo usados aqui, como frequentemente ocorre em algoritmos quânticos iterativos.
Em vez disso, ao alimentar a solução de cada iteração como entrada para a próxima, o algoritmo de otimização quântica
biased field digitized refina incrementalmente o estado fundamental, aproximando-o cada vez mais do
estado final evoluído. E combinado com protocolos counter-adiabáticos, podemos fazer isso mesmo com circuits quânticos de curta profundidade
que devem funcionar suavemente em hardware ruidoso. Então, quando o experimento foi realizado, os autores escolheram executar o
algoritmo no computador quântico IBM Brisbane de 127 qubits. Aqui o autor mostrou
a otimização do algoritmo de otimização para uma instância de vidro de spin gerada aleatoriamente de primeiros vizinhos
com mais de 100 qubits. Eles compararam os resultados de simulação ideais do DCQ e do BF-DCQ
assim como o resultado experimental, e também mostram um resultado de um solver clássico chamado Gurobi como referência.
Com apenas 10 iterações, o BF-DCQ fornece uma melhoria drástica em comparação com o
DCQ. Embora o resultado experimental seja um pouco diferente do resultado ideal devido ao ruído, o desempenho ainda é
melhor do que o DCQ ideal. Isso mostra que ainda há muito progresso excelente sendo feito em relação
à otimização quântica, e bons resultados estão sendo reportados com mais de 100 qubits pela
primeira vez. Por último, mas não menos importante, há um artigo muito interessante explorando a predição da estrutura de mRNA dos nossos amigos da
Moderna Pharmaceuticals, chamado mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility scale quantum
computers. Para começar, se você, como eu, ainda não fez um curso de biologia há alguns anos, pode se atualizar sobre o que
é mRNA. O RNA mensageiro é um tipo de RNA envolvido na síntese de proteínas. Ele
basicamente lê as instruções fornecidas pelo DNA. A estrutura secundária do mRNA é mais ou menos como a cadeia é dobrada, e
o problema de predição da estrutura secundária de RNA é o problema de encontrar a dobramento mais estável da sequência
de bases de nucleotídeos que compõem o DNA e o RNA, que seriam C, G, U e A. Esta
imagem aqui mostra algumas das estruturas de dobramento comuns encontradas no mRNA; cada cor destacada aqui mostra uma
estrutura secundária diferente, mas as características exatas do que torna uma dessas estruturas mais favorável do que
outra não é bem compreendida. Tudo que podemos fazer é descobrir qual tem a menor energia livre em comparação com o
estado não-dobrado, e é aí que os computadores quânticos entram. Então, por que as estruturas secundárias de mRNA são
importantes? Bem, a predição precisa delas é crucial não apenas para entender o DNA e nossos genes, mas também
para projetar terapias baseadas em RNA, como a vacina contra a covid-19. Há razão para acreditar que a abordagem neste
artigo funcionaria porque isso há muito é conhecido como um formidável problema de otimização para os
computadores clássicos, devido ao vasto número de configurações possíveis. E para algumas configurações é realmente conhecido ser
um problema NP-completo. Porém, em um computador quântico podemos formular a predição da estrutura secundária como um
problema de otimização binária, algo que sabemos como tratar. Além disso, já houve evidências na literatura
de predição precisa de RNA em dispositivos quânticos de pequena escala e simuladores quânticos. Então a pergunta óbvia é:
isso funcionaria em hardware maior? O experimento é feito usando algo chamado conditional value
at risk variational quantum eigensolver, que é uma modificação do algoritmo VQE tradicional e tem
expectativa de alcançar uma convergência melhor. Este gráfico mostra a distribuição das probabilidades de medição
das cadeias de bits de amostra com as energias correspondentes para uma instância de 42
nucleotídeos e 80 qubits. Aqui as cadeias de bits simbolizam os pares dos
nucleotídeos. O gráfico ilustra que a cadeia de bits de menor energia tem um valor de energia de -140, que corresponde à cadeia de bits de menor
energia encontrada pelo solver clássico comparativo. Então isso é ótimo, e esta é a estrutura dobrada ótima
dessa cadeia de nucleotídeos com base na cadeia de bits de menor energia que o hardware encontrou.
E com isso chegamos ao final deste episódio. Meu objetivo aqui não era te sobrecarregar com
detalhes de diferentes artigos de pesquisa. Como disse, eu simplesmente queria te dar contexto suficiente para entender como é o
trabalho de ponta no campo hoje. A esperança é que isso acenda algumas engrenagens na
cabeça de todo mundo e que, ao ver como os outros estão abordando os problemas, você seja capaz de fazer conexões e ter
confiança para tentar novos experimentos quânticos que talvez não tentaria antes. E talvez alguns deles não
deem certo, e tudo bem, é por isso que isso é pesquisa. Avançando, lembra que os tipos de problemas que estamos
interessados podem ser agrupados por metodologia ou por assunto, e nós descrevemos aqueles que acreditamos serem
os mais promissores no curto prazo. Lembra que a Computação Quântica não é boa para tudo, e na verdade isso é apenas um
testemunho de como ficamos bons na computação clássica. Só porque você acha que poderia aplicar a Computação Quântica
a um problema não significa que vai gerar resultados interessantes. Infelizmente, você tem que considerar a escala. A profundidade do circuit
é uma faca de dois gumes: precisamos que ela seja consideravelmente grande para fazer trabalhos interessantes que os
computadores clássicos não conseguem, mas agora, por causa do ruído do hardware, não podemos aumentá-la demais porque a fidelidade irá
diminuir. É tudo sobre encontrar aquele ponto ideal, sabendo que é um alvo em movimento. Então dedica um tempo
entre agora e o próximo episódio para realmente pensar sobre alguns problemas com os quais você já se deparou e como gostaria de abordá-los com o que
aprendemos até agora. Seja criativo e não se limite. E se tiveres alguma ideia, mesmo que aches que é um
pouco louca, me conta nos comentários abaixo. Obrigada por assistir e até a próxima.